yeah I'm on the faculty of the
mathematics department which is
sponsoring as we want to thank our math
department staff especially Joanne for
hoping but we have the help from the
Yale office of new haven in state
affairs from the pl undergraduate mass
society we're helping out with the
tables out front and from the coop icing
will be ok so we're great with all of
those and we have some funding from the
NSF who are already ready for that let
me also mention our this is our second
talk our third talk will be December
second the speaker is Alex comes ravitch
from our own Department his talk is
going to be about number theory don't
talk about prime numbers and the
remaining offices and the saxophone so
which which he plays very well so will
come for that and we'd have after this
talk though we two things w are you our
usual prize drawing for people to fill
out a big heart so if you did will draw
a card at random and you'll get a
valuable gift and then we'll have a
workshop so George part of our speaker
today is going to tell you about all
this stuff he's going to lead a workshop
at the end which takes an extra 30 to 60
minutes so if you so we hope you'll have
time to stay for that and you can end up
building your own object so that's it
for pronounced a bunch of our secret so
George heart our speaker over it
days from Stony Brook he's a
mathematician computer scientist a
sculptor and an educator he's got many
things he think he's built and exhibited
many geometric scultures who saw some of
the smaller things out from his led
various innovative workshops he's
written books about geometry and a lot
of uses of mathematics and engineering
he's taught at various universities and
I think most of all he knows how to
knows how to really have fun with
patterns and how to think about using
patterns to understand the world better
that's really what Maddux is about so I
look for their du jour short thank you
ok thank you all for coming up thank you
for inviting me and I'm a mathematician
its culture I like to make cool man
things I like that I enjoyed that so
much you like to show other people how
fun and exciting methods you may not see
as much as math as I've seen in my life
so I trying to take parts of man that I
think are cool and explain to you why
they're called in a visual sculptural
form so some of you so I had outside of
the table a bunch of little models I
broke them all in here so I can point
them out you're welcome to come at the
end in and look these and pick them up
I'll mention some of them they all have
a kind of a geometric story these are
all made by a committed but they all
start like what you see on the screen I
designed something in my head I think of
something mathematical idea I figure out
a way to represent on the computer and
then I send
computer to machine that actually built
it makes it real I'll show you a whole
different things here
good okay so i start with mathematical
ideas and I transform them first into a
computer and then into sculpture and
I'll show you an assortment of things
here let me ask first is the light okay
people can see we don't have to lower
the room lights yes good okay so this is
a sculpture made out of CDs is that big
and it has a mathematical pattern to it
does anyone recognize the shape can you
tell me what's the underlying
mathematical idea yes it's a bunch of
circles he has the circles of the cds
and how are they put together are they
in a line you see hexagons okay so I
have a pointer make a point with this oh
so for example here might be a hexagon
and I'm three my ex again yeah and but
what's this hexagon so there's some
hexagons some Pentagon's we recognize
the shape how we ever seen it before
soccer ball yeah it's none of the same
shape of the soccer ball and the soccer
ball the Pentagon's the five-sided ones
would be black and Mexicans the
six-headed ones would be white long
before people invented soccer they knew
this shape the shape of the well over
2,000 years old is called a truncated
icosahedron if your mathematician it was
discovered about 20 years ago that it
shows up in nature so it's actually more
than 2,000 years old with millions
years old fifth carbon can take carbon
atoms and if you have a candle in the
fire there's carbon that the atoms get
loose in the flame and then they come
together they tend to naturally make
this shape there's something called a
buckyball if you've ever heard of that
ball yeah so this is form of carbon like
carbon and graphite would have diamonds
and like coal and carbon can also make
the shape where each of it the pink
things you see size of the cds would be
where carbon edges anyway examples of
how geometry shows up in chemistry in
many other fields I like to take
mathematics and apply it to sculpture to
art and design so you're probably
familiar with how mathematics is used in
science and engineering and accounting
in many many different fields but you
can add that this feels Art and Design
people who are doing art are doing
things with patterns and structures as
much as you're doing mathematics in any
other feel so i'll just show you a bunch
of sculptures if there's also the
question how do you hope piece together
and how do you glue them and the sort of
engineering questions of how you make
these culture I'll talk a little bit
about so much but it's mostly about some
of the math so this is basically a
truncated icosahedron to a mathematician
so this is a larger sculpture make the
cds what shapes do you see here
c square well maybe the angles limited
off it's not exactly squares but there
are 4-sided shapes there and you may be
able to see some kite shapes as so from
there to here to here this is an example
of a kite shape and there's a bunch of
other kite shape so for example here is
one and there are also triangles here's
an equilateral triangle two equal signs
and it turns out this whole sphere it's
about two meters in diameter is made of
kite shapes and equilateral triangles
this is a this is a commission for the
computer science building at UC Berkeley
University in California and they had a
big space and I designed the sculpture
here in New York and I figured out the
lens some angles of all the slots and I
cut CDs with the slots in them a ship
that house ultra in a box that was less
than a 1 foot cute as just the cds over
there and then i went and i assembled it
because we got two days to put it
together and it's hanging way up high in
the atrium had to go up analista it was
kind of a fun project but part of what
led me to choose the shape while i was
interested in it is because it is made
of kites and triangle than i have never
seen the shape boards a shape that I
discover then it goes kind of cool and
what's really cool is that the cream
shapes has three angles that are equal
so if you look at the kite this this
angle here at the top of a kite if this
is the bottom of the time to shoot one
kite that's where the tail will be exact
this angle here in this angle here and
this name here are equal so it has three
equal angles and one angle that's
different and it has mirror symmetry the
left and the right of the same and I
thought that was kind of strange that
that's that's too many constraints that
all that could be true at once no sort
of surprised and happy
find the shake and I wanted to somehow
let other people know about the shape so
one thing you could do is you could
write a mathematical pay for this as i
discovered the shape and it has these
interesting tronic level Hey or you
could just make a sculpture and show
people that they can sort of see for
themselves I chose to make a sculptor
better so again each of my sculptures
has some interesting little story that's
interesting to me and I try and bring it
out and then when viewers see the
sculpture I hope they get curious they
start thinking what's the pattern there
and one of those lengths and angles
whatever and they need you to think
about mathematics if you realize that
mathematics it's a very rich and fun
subject okay so what do we have here we
have much pencils you could probably
guess how many there's 72 pencils so
what's happening is if you look at any
one color you might see a hexagon 65 is
24 different hexagons it is four
different colors and they all pass
through the center so that means in the
center there's a room there's a space
that which the walls are those pencils
and if you are a little mouse or
something you can live inside that room
and what shape room would that be what
kind of room has walls that are shaped
so that the sunlight was exactly along
the pencil beams the shadow of your room
would be a hexagon in four different
directions so if you imagine the Sun
lining up with the pencils they there
outlining the space of Sun and the space
inside happens to be a shameful the
rhombic dodecahedron does not a shaker
probably familiar one but it's a shame I
like it's a very important shape in
crystallography for example lots of
little crystals that receiving Adams
line up according to that shape has some
wonderful properties but one of those
properties is that has four different
hexagon shadows so I wanted to make a
little sculpture that somehow expresses
that idea and
alignment with this this particular
version of the sculptor I've made 25
different ones with different pencils so
they're all unique if they all have the
same geometry the jig I news for holding
it in place when I glue it can be the
same 25 times for this when I chose
pencils that are cyan magenta yellow and
black that see my HK set of colors are
used by printers to print things so if
you look pretty pictures of magazines
and books use those four colors so i
chose pencils of those four colors and
by choosing the proportions more more
more than other you can blend together
packaging any combat you can imagine any
color you've ever seen in a book these
four columns so depending on where you
stand or as you turn sculpture you'll
see more work because it is sort of also
dialing around different positions
different concentrations of colors if
you look at it from a distance it could
be more of one or more to another this
is a sculpture like a traditional mosaic
retake squares any movement any want to
guess how many pieces are have a number
300 500 sounded like again and that is
902 ok so to work it out a lot of
mathematical ideas that come up with
this and there's a lot more pieces that
you think a lot of work took about a
month to make this I first had to make a
sphere and then I have to locate points
on the sphere so perhaps you've done
drawing with the compass in a straight
edge where you can create an equilateral
triangle
doesn't a geometry class McClurkin
compass what you're doing with the
compass is your locating points on a
plane that are the corners of some shape
you're interested they can say squared
you have to figure out how many exact
square I had to work out techniques to
locate the core points on a sphere with
a set of points that I wanted to make so
there's some interesting mathematical
challenges technical challenges for me
behind the scene is that that I sort of
enjoyed rubbing against how do i sync my
idea and end up making to a real
sculpture then I had to cut out these
ninety two pieces it just might shake
and coumadin and fitter and I like to
look at the road sort of see your I can
kind of follow the yellow brick roads
from one spot to another and final isn't
a semester this is a larger metal
sculpture this is about five feet
diameter and a peacock and here I'm
interested in the color pattern is a
branch of mathematical combinatorics
that looks bad things combined and count
how many systematic are what you'll see
the count here there are exactly five
colors you see that each of those loose
crosses for other colors and you notice
that they're always crossing the other
four colors so the yellow one frozen
green our internet and blue the ends of
the loops always come together in groups
of three of the same color so wherever
we see the end of one loop you find
three groups of that same color and if
you look around the five-sided openings
you'll see that there's always all five
the different colors there so there's
some interesting work behind the scenes
to make all that happened how can I make
all those things happen at once yes it
would be underlying pattern and I chose
for making this culture
this was a commission for a library
could actually in 1999 at the turn of
the century at one of the big sculpture
so what I proposed was that they set up
a Boeing booth and everyone who comes
the library could write into three
favorite votes of the century that
whatever three favorite books are and
the librarians total them and I used to
computer control rather to carve the
titles and authors in these wooden
things that look like books but they're
actually Hollow and along the spine of
each book there's a steel rod and I
brought all these pieces to the library
and I had a view cast those little
doughnut so they made of bronze and I
drilled holes for the steel rods to go
in and all holes for screws so it had
like an instant sculpture kick and I
brought this thing they are names you
put up signs you come to the sculpture
barn-raising and 100 people came and I
had no idea it's going to take an hour's
it's going to take all day something
terrible to happen but it took about two
hours to build and nothing terrible
happened Hadley's worried someone's
going to steal a book or something books
going to break whatever but its ties
together with a very interesting complex
sequence to get everything there so each
event donuts has holes in it for the
steel rod each book has a steel rod
imagine you build everything attend one
last book to go you couldn't stick the
book in at both ends because the rod
that everything else would already be in
place it's sort of like a problem of
putting the toilet paper holder in the
wall so when the toilet paper holder you
can kind of squeeze it it has like one
has a rod that squeezes it goes into
then expands I wasn't that fancy so
instead I designed it where all the
edges are parallel this is a particular
type of shape called a zona he drew the
zona Heejun is a class of polyhedra
forms where all the edges come in
parallel families so you can cut this in
half and one hands connects to the other
half with ten rods that are parallel so
they can all join it once and then each
of those halves can be built in two
halves that
when you go to experience a parallel so
the whole thing's would be sort of
divided the anthem ham ham ham just have
to mentally play that backwards to put
this together I've been people at the
library and number one book of the
library picture with the catcher in the
rye that was a top folding book and
there's a pattern to how the numbers go
around etc so I'd like to do these
things I call sculpture barn raisings
and the house where you some pictures
any case so I have a lot of sculptures
here and I'm not going to tell you about
all of them because it would take a long
time they each have us an interesting
story this one I'll just say a word
about this is about a meter in diameter
the University in Spain it's a hundred
and eighty pieces their laser cut wood
and the thing that's hard to believe or
understand is that each of those pieces
where every two pieces join there's a
lot of carpet ripples a mortise and
tenon joint that means that there's a
hole in one at the end of the other that
kind of sticks out and it goes through a
slot and then as a whole for a pin that
goes a little wooden pins and wedges in
their class together I laser cut all
those pieces and the laser cuts
perpendicular to the surface with on
right angle subscribers that means we're
never to point to pieces join to join it
right angles so everything you're seeing
there whenever the piece of joint is a
90 degree angle and it looks like how
can those benighted reality really is
crazy princesa but in fact I started
from that constraint knowing that the
laser cutter cuts at right angles I said
to myself well I could make like a cube
that would have right angles or I can
make something with more x equals and
then I sort of challenge myself what's
the most complex interesting thing I can
make that only uses right angles until I
came to this with enormous
right angles in here so it's completely
regular there's all these curves but the
joints are all at 90 degrees so that was
actually my prototype a wooden one meter
diameter before making a larger scale
version over this is too even though
this is at stony brook university in the
computer science building and the cannon
uses the same techniques something
different proportions because the metal
is stronger than what it could be
thinner but again joins together with
the mortise and tenon joints and a
little cotter pins as via pins here's a
kind of a sculpture that doesn't have
any nuts and bolts or glue or whatever
so what I was doing here is challenging
myself to come up with a shape that
locks together and you have to kind of
bend a little the last one a little bit
kind of spring it into place but once
it's in there it all pushes against each
other so there's 20 pieces of the shape
you see on the right and it's very
carefully calculated so that they rest
against each other and it's completely
self-contained it is not glued or welded
or anything I think if you took out one
piece so just go shooting across the
room and I had he was like a big wooden
letters you won't get that last piece in
and it kind of bend it to snap it in
place but that is incredibly very solid
so instead of just steel powder coated
red and you can see the little notches
six notches in the shape on the rain
where each one connects to six other
pieces and that's the holds it together
so the last one is unlocked up together
until that last one was in it would just
fall apart how big is that one something
about this big maybe seven or eight
inches and I should mention the
construction that we're going to do
today that you're going to do those of
you to stay after we're going to make it
structure out of playing cards which has
the same cracking that all falls apart
until the last one gets to get in goes
together so maybe a little frustrating
to get that last piece it's a sort of
the thing that I've gotten used to and i
think i can get you so here's just sort
of a similar idea but a much more
complex piece but again the very last
piece has a kind of snap took place to
lock this together but there's a much
more complex and interlocking this was a
retirement present for a friend of mine
a professor a professor who retired and
he likes puzzles so I designed a puzzle
for him there's 30 separate pieces and
they all talk together in this complex
quake and they look like a long bar with
a head on each end while chasing up when
facing down and in the back ahead is a
kind of a notch and the notch is all
locked together and the neck there's a
kind of a notch and getting us all
together and getting that last piece in
the assembly trip to this puzzle it's
about this big oh I should mention I
have a model better if you can see this
at all but sometimes going to make a
sculpture I'd like to have it forever
I'd like to keep it but there a lot of
work to make i'm only making one one of
a kind so the actual one that i made is
gone you know give it away as a present
but i made myself a little longer but I
can keep to kind of remind me of
made on a 3d printer and I'll show you
much more thing vid on a 3d printer I
think this is another sculpture it sort
of picture probably invited to talk
about but again it's my own model and
the actual sculpture somewhere else this
I did as a barn-raising full maybe about
five years ago I was artist in resident
at MIT and use the laser cutter there to
cut out these pieces and then how to
open for people help me put together
this one sculpture this is a wooden
sculpture less than 2 feet 9 18 inches
which way I did first before building a
much larger version 2 is about four feet
diameter and then I made a regent larger
metal burger so what idea that you can
do is kind of fun is to make things up
paper so what you see here is 12 copies
of that shape on the left so if you can
cut out that shape very carefully and
interweave if the parts have is very
complex and of interdigitating how the
fingers go through each other it's a
puzzle for me to fill and then you
probably can't see once you're sitting
very fun but at the ends of all those
fingers as little slots and the little
slots just slide together and I can just
barely see it here so the whole thing
just goes together by weakness all
together slightly slots a minute Oh
locks in place and again the the fingers
and the spacers are carefully calculated
ahead of time so that they don't bump
into each other so that when I do
but everything just barely passes other
pieces okay that's kind of challenge
that I like to myself my designers
things and then I have to figure out
some way to build it the same idea but
more pieces more complex so two of those
pieces that look like a three overlap
one upside down to make this each shape
and then again there's little notches
which you may not be able to see on the
screen there at the ends of those tabs
and the notches just slide together and
the paper friction Holden pullen park so
it took me about a half a day to figure
out how I might make it and then another
affidavit actually built it once I had
the strategy that works getting all
those pieces before they're all there
I'm going to get it all that kind of
much more organized than it is but
before is 11 is half done everything is
falling apart and you don't know there's
a piece go in front or behind another
piece in there so I enjoy that kind of
challenge this on the other hand is a
much simpler thing to make this is a
kind of a topological surface so I think
last week's talk is about technology
some of you were here may have learned
something about surfaces and edges this
is one continuous surface it has just
one side has six edges and it makes an
interesting kind of pattern and I like
this idea so I wanted to make it real
it's actually made of wire I took a wire
to build this whole shape and then I
coated it with paper mache and painted
it white so it's paper mache built over
a wire frame I gave me the geometry a
similar idea more complex made of
acrylic plastic or plexiglass so each of
those pieces of plastic has it twisted I
had two heated in an oven to soften it
to get the plastic soft and then put the
twisted one and put it in a jig that
held it exactly at the right angle when
I once let it cool down and then I had
the pieces and then I had to ascend
the pieces glued them together and this
plastic is very rigid doesn't not like
rubber doesn't flex so everything has to
be exactly right one little gas that
would be the google Peter so it has to
be very carefully worked out to go look
this is a minute collect plastic talk
about all these again there's something
about the net I like something about the
assembly that was probably a challenge
on to build so this is made of 3d
printing so what you have here is a big
shape of mathematician applause
icosahedron and each icosahedron is made
of smaller icosahedron each of those
made those fallen shape is kind of a
fractal shape and it's got many many
pieces have just barely touch each other
to connect there's no way I can build
with my hand if I had to carve this out
of so for wood or butter or metal or
whatever it's just too complex to do
that there's no way I can make little
pieces and put them together there
wasn't sticking point the only
technology that can make this type of
communication so what we can I a cure me
a 3d printer is a machine that I can
design a shape on the computer I can
basically hit this print button and the
Machine built it and the way it works is
I designed the shape I think what I want
solid line one here and the computer can
calculate through each cross section let
Z equals 0 points1 point2 for every say
thousands of an inch what the cross
section of my shape looks like and
prints that cross section using material
a thousandth of an inch dick and then
stack all those cross sections so this
is made of nylon on a very fancy 3d
printer at stony brook university might
cost about a quarter of million dollars
and each of these layers is built on top
of the other but working how you're not
so you have a bucket of powder Thailand
very fine powder a computer controlled
laser draws on with hot enough to melt
it but it only draw us partly one solid
then that cross section is melted and
fuses together the rest of your powder
is still powder and is sitting in a
Christian that goes down a thousandth of
an inch a little supply chamber comes up
brings more powder little sweetie roller
flattens it out and then the laser notes
the second cross section and that melts
that won't blow it and it keeps doing
this melt go down at bournemouth longer
until you build up all these layers and
the loose powder your vacuum away at the
end and what's left foot to infuse to
get your object it's expensive it's
fancy and uses the much more complex
makes it was like a big chillin system
hangers and liquid nitrogen etc so the
nylon doesn't burn but in the end you
can make anything you can think of so
whatever you can think of it you can
describe into the computer this machine
can build it as long as nothing I
smaller bit about a thousand 00 so I
have a number of models here that are
made on that machine and this is one
they enable me to take very complex
ideas and bring them out so here's one
of a series of objects based on what I
called hyperbolic tessellations so
mathematicians study all kinds of spaces
what kind of space is called a
hyperbolic space in hyperbolic space in
some senses it's a different set of
rules and Alice traits that they're
consistent rules so if you look at the
ceiling you'll see here at each point
you can put four squares around ok so
you can put four squares around a point
in an exactly fit in our ordinary space
in hyperbolic space you can change the
rules that maybe you can put say five
squares about this point
six or more there's a lot more room in
hyperbolic space you can do more things
so I took some ideas when I called
uniform tessellations so at each little
vertex today our things meet they need
the same way and it's a very regular
pattern look at it carefully and they're
all equal sized holes that fit together
their uniform regular weight in
hyperbolic space but that can't live in
our space so I haven't kind of transform
it there's ways that mathematicians sort
of take patterns and other spaces and
distort them as little as possible here
i use something called a want or a disk
as a way to transform that idea to this
space and then turn that into a
sculpture that sort of shows something
about the patterns i was interested in
and also i tried to create kind of an
undersea underwater feeling that this is
something that you might find swimming
around in the ocean and as part of a
series that again take these local
uniform tessellations hyperbolic plane
and transform them into sculptures so
here perhaps you can see in the IDF I if
I use my mouse well if I look at any one
corner say here I have a square one with
four sides and then I have one with five
sides and then I have one with four
sides and I home with my sons in fact in
every vertex everywhere for things neat
there's square Pentagon square Pentagon
and they're all regular and all the
pentagon city call all the squares are
equal in hyperbolic space but we can't
do that in our space so I have to kind
of distorted that changes the proportion
of competence and of those little or
pieces as you get to the edges but it
illustrates this pattern that ever
interested in so we can only fit four
squares you couldn't put Pentagon
have too many angles too many degrees in
our space but we can do that type of
Alex base this is also made on a 3d
printer I won't say anything about this
is that that's actually it was buried in
a time capsule about five years ago it's
going to be dug up in 45 more years sort
of representing the state of art
technology curious to see if people in
50 years like it or not i'll show you a
couple of pictures of Israel about 8
inches these were centerpieces for a
fancy mathematical dinner and we have
interesting colors and these are built
on a color 3d printer so there are 3d
pictures that not only make the shape my
warms but can assign color to every
point and so i can use mathematical
algorithms to decide how I want them
colored as a machine Bill of them as I
had these about eight inches here again
I'm trying to get to have an undersea
look but each of these has would have a
different idea that I was trying to
create
and one more 3d printed objects and this
shows you what you can do with this
technology this is a ball about eight
inches in diameter I've made a thousands
of little links like chain mail but I
didn't link them together it was built
linked so what you see here each of
those pieces were built in these players
in the form that you see it and then
when you remove the powder what you have
is basically like a fabric things can
move the overall shape has 12 these soft
spots the next picture oh this is the
closest to show you what the links look
like and so this machine can make very
tiny little pieces if you tell it all
the little pieces you want so on the
right you can see what holds it together
why doesn't this thing is all flat like
if you have a bag of chain on the table
which is my plan what I did for the blue
section is I made the pieces a little
fatter so that they lock into each other
and they aren't flexible chain they're
glued together like they become one will
ride but for the intersection that's
colored red I made just enough space so
that the chain is free to move the blue
part is kind of a scaffold that holds
the overall shape and the red parts
flexibles you shaking around they move
like cloth and what's interesting is
that no matter how you hold it the top
six parts of is 12 of these pentagonal
the chopsticks kind of sag down and the
bottom sticks also said yeah we have you
need to take us the bottom half looks
around and the top 10 PCBs dimples and
when you turn it different ways it
always looks like that now here's a
sculpture I did this to the University
of Michigan
they had this big space they built a big
science center and they said can I
design a big sculpture for it and it was
too big for me to make a big skull but I
can't make it up to that big how much a
little sculptures Malaysia okay so these
are each 4 feet in diameter and there's
nine of them that span this room which
is about 120 feet long and they start
the far end yellow and each one if you
come a little closer they get a little
more orange or orange to come to the one
that's near the camera near which is red
and actually each have two colors and
each one is a slightly different change
from the Monday night so the very for
one that's small near the yellow one
that's made of what's called an
icosahedron and I build equity the two
well-known shapes that mathematician
study and they're both together there
they kind of go through each other in a
nice way slightly curved but if you look
at it you'll see very clearly you'll
recognize my host occasion and I going
to eat but for the next shape I kind of
bent the edges a little bit like a
straight little bit and then for the
next shape I bent it more and i had a
piece that was in front now comes around
back behind the other and then if you
come further there's like a hole in the
pieces and as you get through home with
a little change i'll go change the
rotation tell you get to the piece of
closest to the county here and it's a
very complex exploding flower light
thing and it's not all obvious where it
comes from unless you look at the whole
sequence so to me this is somehow kind
of like a metaphor for what a
mathematician does with a creative proof
so the idea of a proof is that a math
teacher starts with known simple things
that everyone likes and agreed as I say
I believe those facts and then combine
seven goes a little change will change
and you build up sequence of steps until
you end up with something new and
surprising and this is sort of
illustrating the idea of approved the
idea of the derivation of a little
change at a time starting for something
this was something kind of wonderful and
fun in a visual sculptural way so Miss
acted as a barn-raising it has the
pictures here of putting it together so
there's our close up so what I do is I
design these knowledge boards they each
have pieces you see and then a couple of
hundred little brackets and lots of nuts
and bolts all together there's over
18,000 pieces in this overall thing I
wasn't going to get 18 thousand pieces I
put up a sign come to barn raising so
everyone come help me to forget
everything so the whole campus came and
helped me assemblies over about four
hours of the morning agency set of the
steps of making these pieces and
brackets and screwing them together and
each one is different so I had to run
around from table to table sort of
helping people with a particular shape
of that they were building which all
slightly different before we hung them
up and that's the final result of so I
have a little video that I'm going to
interrupt this part of the talk and
switch to some videos and show you this
so this is a time lapse of building over
the period of you'll see in one minute
while was actually about four hours
putting all these parts together so
there's an inner layer and then there's
like an outer layer with two different
shapes of the big pieces of school
slightly different colors
I was like in some soldier and seed has
already changed after the ceiling I
worked out where I want to the pump you
have the building people put these
chains so then they came in with a list
they can look them all up get each one
up into place
it's a sculpture that's good albion
college in michigan if you're ever in
the Detroit area check that out oh so
now I'll show you a different sculpture
that i did at the bar this is a 3d
printed model i showed you this colloquy
the model about 10 inches across that I
did before building the sculpture just
so I can look at the full made of
triangles back at the triangles are flat
and have them have a little band in this
all carefully worked out to fit together
to into shape and I have a laser cutting
company cut out the metal pieces and I
brought them all this was actually done
on the mall in washington DC outside US
than Semyon about two years ago you can
see the park there and just have anyone
want to come to this table to help me
put it together and there's a very
complex plan for which pieces of which
colors is 14 colors whether the bench
and I feel together one arrangement but
this work out in about two and a half
days getting all these pieces assembled
building larger and larger modules I've
kind of went together until there's the
final sculpture that's called gyro angle
but it's based on surface mathematicians
pulling gyroid service which is a a very
wiggly fun thing and I figured out a way
to make that of triangles with the cold
which is the basis for this culture I
was used actually as a logo for a
conference so if you like this sort of
thing if you like math and or a lot
there's conferences and in every field
their conferences where professions come
together and sort of show a few ideas
and talk to other experts and
so get a creativity recharge what's
going on so this fuel up anthem heart
this is brigette countries which was
couple months ago it's one every year
with a thousand University happen to use
my sculpture because it's at Towson
University and as you just mentioned
there's also a journal so if you're a
professional you want to hear an
academic you want to publish papers
about your research in this area there's
a place for the journal mathematic
remarks today people often ask me
conniving a kid something that they can
build these sculptures themselves so I
did make this kid this is a skull try
make old fractures a one-of-a-kind here
and but for people to make their own
version of it I designed this plastic
kit and you can buy this it's a look
online for practice and it sold the
Museum of mathematics and there's a
fancy Persian with lots of colors as
well and let me say just a bit about the
museum of mathematics so mathematics is
such a cool thing that it needs a fun
museum and not too far from here in New
York City there was a new zealand
mathematics which i've been working up
last four years we're just going to open
this december in about one more month so
basically it's on 11 East 26 street it's
going to be full of hands-on interactive
cool things that are fun to do like you
seen the size museums but where the idea
to learn something fun about math while
doing something exciting here's the kind
of thickness kind of cool here's a
treasure over the wheels or square even
though the wheels are square you get a
perfectly smooth ride that was that
possible well the floor compensates for
the square
you solve the right equation you can
discover that the floor has to be what's
called a catenary curve a catenary does
the curve that you get your whole piece
of chain chain name down and makes a
shade and looks something like a
parabola it's a little bit different so
if you turn that upside down to make it
kind of a bump and you have a series of
those the corners of the wheels go
through into the bus and the axle the
center of the square stays at a constant
height and the triangle the tricycle
rides on the axle so if you have a
smooth ride as we made a random one with
two of these one goes clockwise windows
coming back I like to design activities
this is the kind of a hands-on building
thing they had a piece of sets free
together that can also be also
associated with museum and let me just
quickly show you a series of things that
I've written up of fun man things you
can do at home so there's a series
called math Monday's that I wrote for
Make Magazine it's just google math
mondays you'll find a whole list of
these here's an instructions on how to
take a bagel and cut it into two pieces
that are equal and that of each a closed
loop but instead of coming apart as you
normally slice a bagel they're linked
together filling the chain and there it
is so your own assignment for tomorrow
is to get some bagels for breakfast in
cut the premise way that they're linked
together and the instructions if you
just google link bangs you find it
here's a kind of construction kit the
laser cut pieces that connect together
to make a big thing this I believe
you'll be able to play with
we see the mathematics this is an
activity actually designed by my
daughter my daughter by heart also likes
all the same things I like poor man
things when she have a serious video
Google very fun thing she learned how to
make balloons into dogs and poodles or
whatever and said well why don't we also
make tetrahedron octahedron so she
created some geometric things out of
balloons you can google map those are
fun I decided to make something else
this is like a ship in a bottle but this
is an octahedron inside a balloon and
interesting question how would you make
an octahedron inside a balloon that
year's work if you google my watch angel
to find the solution at the head of your
neck very very careful yet taxing very
very easy now tired what you do is you
start with the balloon inside out and
you want the fourths on the outside and
you're glue with rubber cement the
strip's wherever you want to go inside
out and then you turn it the other way
around you blow it up and you have your
thing inside the balloon much easier
than shipping a Model T let the balloon
you turn the tab here's just a fun thing
you can make with light sticks these
glow-in-the-dark and they help the other
rubber bands make a giant structure this
is a CD thing that you can put together
with sort of cable ties to make might
recognize the truncated icosahedron
again the buckyball the soccer ball in
this form here's how hyper employed
I you forgetting to hold things up for
you but here's I'm a paranoid shape is
made of straight lines and there would
you can make it out of skewers and
little pony tail and rubber bands that
hold everything together and it's
flexible it squeezes and opens in it
it's all made of two families of
straight lines and here's what you guys
going to make it really large taking 25
bit circles a lot of string big enough
to stand and sign it this is a toy that
you may have seen outside of one of the
tables pulled over here zoom tool is
designed by architect making domes but
it turns out to be really good for make
it lots of other things what you're
seeing here is a three-dimensional
shadow of a four dimensional object so
just as we study geology in three
dimensions you can step back and think
in higher dimension before dimensions
interestin that is a great book called
flatline 20 feet about four dimensional
space this is a very interesting
beautiful thing four dimensions that we
take its shadow as a three-dimensional
object and I built it with get about
five or six thousand pieces of zone tool
using 50 people to help me out in
Central Park in New York City one day so
a lot of people came he built this thing
left it out there and everyone was
walking through the park would come and
see this okay what is that me say well
it's a vegetable shadow away for this
long bow 602 and they say they say don't
you do this back in France or back in
your city wherever you go anyway so it's
kind of a fun thing that we took it all
apart it was just a one-day sculpture so
I mentioned some 3d printers that can
make fancy things there's also little 3d
printers that you
there's many different companies honor
the world of anxieties this is one
called the MakerBot which is about this
big and it can melt plastic it takes
kind of a fishing line there that melts
it and that it uses voters to squirt out
that finger plastic kind of filled up is
if you have like a hot melt glue gun
that you were screaming like using the
robot to build up early and quite a few
of these objects here are made on that
machine and it looks like that I'll just
show you a couple of pictures of things
that's the first thing I felt it would
make up is a little tetrahedron is a
dodecahedron some extra stuff but that's
what it looks like if you clean it up
Stewart was adjusting everything I like
to design puzzles so that's a puzzle
made of twelve sticks I got some others
take puzzles here but they they
interlock the piece of the loose until
you snap them together and then they
hold together that's when I was just
showing you this oh no I think it's my
dad anyway i will show you this
sometimes but it's made of two parts
that snap together and ink up all the
different ways it's kind of fun yeah
this is definitely in my bag this is a
classic puzzle
but puzzle is a think of what shape
would fit snugly through a square
through a triangle and through a circle
it's kind of an interesting challenge is
there a three-dimensional shape though
with exactly snugly fit through and the
answer is a kind of a wedge you see on
the right has a circle on the bottom and
it comes up with two sides of the square
one part and you can slide through and
have an exactly 52 those different holes
and that's a that's a Paula my first
point as a kid so many more important
both and if you're interested in so
learning about mathematics in different
ways I strongly recommend look up books
by martin gardner they're written to
show you sort of the fun side of
mathematics and in all different aspects
including pups this is a lighter or not
so what happens when I was at home one
day and somehow one of my little nephews
are somebody lost the light dimmer knob
off the wall oh gosh I guess I'll go to
the harvester but I liked him enough now
I'm standing right next to my 3d printer
and think that I go like the why don't I
just make the light dinner nom I have a
pretty print so what would be a cool
light enough obviously one based on a
hyperbolic tessellation so this I took
one of those installations from the
hyperbolic plane and wrapped it around
the hemisphere to make a kind of an
island and built it and this won't they
designed a quarter inch hole on the back
that slides over the knob it works fine
but the really cool thing is after I
made it I took a picture and put it on
my website and then once you have these
3d models you can download from the
internet so like the next day I'm
getting email from the Netherlands and
from New Zealand people said cool liked
it or not I made one too so like whether
you design something did the whole the
idea that your designs can be spread
around the world of people who like them
okay so let me F up now I'm going to
show you I think a video or two but let
me first say I feel some things out of
cards and what we're going to do at the
end of my talk is a car
construction these are some card
constructions wanted rato 30 40 50 cards
that have slots in them at least night
together this is nothing obstructs we're
going to do today though they're fine
fun constructions you can look them up
on my website this is one may that's 30
cards like all the dough deck and that
also was another time but that would
take about two hours ago so instead to
make this one this one has 12 cards and
it's still complex enough that it may
take almost an hour to bill let me point
out something about the symmetry while I
have this picture here on the screen
many of my sculptures use the idea of
symmetry so what do I mean by something
that's so much something is symmetric
but there's something I can do to it
that makes it look the same so a person
is symmetric if you could reflect that
person in the mirror and they look the
same is the website sustained at your
right side but symmetric to the extent
that reflecting you leaves you unchain
and I think with rotational symmetries I
pulled something here like this if you
look straight down with this object this
has 111 sticks so if I turn this 11th of
a turn or two levels of a turn it looks
the same like if you close your eyes and
I turned it or I didn't earn it you
wouldn't know if I turned it or not the
idea that I can she turn it do this
transformation it looks the same is what
symmetry is about the mathematician so
this sculpture has a three-way symmetry
have a four-way symmetry
two aces so as it goes around you can
see one spot where three cards come
together in this final and they are
about where four cars come together in
this final understanding the symmetry is
key to building a culture so that once
you figure out how a little bit it goes
together everything else is the same
just your building three-way cycles in
fourways night I just wanted to mention
that boy I have that slide there so let
me show you maybe a little video
Saturday so this is a construction where
I designed to shape and I brought it to
a school and I said why don't we cut out
these pieces and the build is really big
and I had no idea this is going to work
it was going to explode if it's going to
hope you I mean you could do a
structural analysis if this was made out
of steel and figure out is it strong
enough to withstand wind alone Matt but
basically I just said look it's going to
build it and hope that it fits together
but maybe it's going to collapse so I
design a template and I brought the
pieces over
or do some cardboard little so also we
can have two pieces and that's the tech
work though what you're seeing is one
card more advanced know that I have made
at home planning that that's shape which
has six slots will exactly fit together
with itself in this complex way and so
we traced it and if you can see there
that's actually a stack of fine pieces
on top of each other so we took like
this is a cardboard and held together
with black binder clips and trace the
template on top and started cutting out
these pieces I didn't really know that
would fit together I just hope it
together
so these pieces joined together first as
a cycle of great that we can kind of a
dream i console and then this module has
to join to the next module and the next
module and there's sort of three levels
of points at a lot of pieces 60 pieces
so we spent a lot of time cutting couple
you coming I just made this video so
usually get things backwards cracks are
going to kind of be careful for that
I've seen the right yellow paper model
so i couldnt knew that and paper would
work but the paper is much more flexible
one of my plans for ways to keep us up
enhancer I want to get a half dozen or
so different designs on display room the
templates online having a car finished
writing the web page from this so that
other people can then take this template
and do this at their school mascot
activity and with the video of
instructions as to how the party go so
we're going to take going over there we
know that honestly tell you that some
places be broken be probably could have
cut some extras but we're some thoughts
criado en exil ESPYs still have a slip
it in the puzzle of it very less piece
that we know less less module clicks it
into the hole to get behind right next
week so we had to stop and think Logan
how do we get that less module him when
it's bigger than the whole
come back with a plan the plan was to
take the three separate pieces and put
it inside individually and build the
model inside
you're doing it to a party say for this
one in this one or not oh yes sort of
like turning around for them so when you
have a cam 3 a pretty good they don't
fall apart that's a lot
you